ロビーだー
業者を前後はぁこんにちははじめ車場です
前髪が足掻くて申し訳ございません動作が家の中に入っていくところ説明させて
いただきますこのとビーバー
なんと
この扉とかいます
パッとリー氏その扉に見えるんですけどもこれ新品でとある細工がされていますどう
でしょう
ほぼ今ある扉と見た目が変わらないと思います
そして
今のかおおですさあ皆さん何がそれかも分かったでしょうか
そして業者さんが基づいていると秒今外してもらってます非常にお腹周りがかゆい
かゆい
電動ドライバーでしっかりと外してもらっております僕はちょっとプロポストールこっ
できません
さあ昔の扉が外されてきました今まで扉さんありがとうございました
そして僕の家にはには扉が
ない状態になっております泥棒さん入るなら今です
今は鍵があります栓付 cd だけは張り替えて新しい扉をこちらに設置させて
いただきます
さあサイズが合うかどうか
ぴったりかピッタリきたかこれぴったりきました
ん
ありがとうございやわーじゃあこちら扉の後ろでございます発泡スチロールで出来て
いるのが分かりますですそう今とびラー
めちゃくちゃ軽くなっておりますもうほんと軽いです
びっくりするくらいからいいですもう本当にこれがキーで使うです
おおぉ通してやディティールが5万回この子の関税もとかですかこの
カブ作るもはいという理由っていつはめちゃくちゃ重い扉なんですけどもその扉も
めちゃくちゃ軽くしましたこれで今から1及びをも gackt 開き何
バーンてきたら
びっくりすると思いましたら怖いわですねこれは本当にかなり軽く作ってもらってるん
で
完全に入ったバンパーシャワー
かわいい本当にいつも軽く作ってるんで図面と彼にバーン
うん何か壊れそうなんであーゲット次第だと思ってますターゲットをしっかり支えて
くれば大丈夫なんですけどもターゲットマート超えてゆけたら壊れちゃうんで当たり
慎重に行こうと思いますでは
me
[音楽]
ねえええマジ
ん
ええええ
[音楽]
涙になにこれああ
ものを出さダンス気にするならなかったら
ん
[音楽]
いやあああああああああああああああ
ああああああ
[音楽]
3で3これ内郷
ニセモノっ
ただけでいつも思え扉が超軽量化して倒れてくるのきれいでした
[音楽]
すごいデキ
うわぁ
[音楽]
dare
ran
[音楽]
rrr わー
バッハ
ラバー
ホームなんですよ
ずっと思いません
よくやってくださいうんバトル瞭然
うーん
相撲
ああああああ
を張っていけねぇん
いいいい
よっ
ああああああっ
ブーブーブーブー l パッケージ
ぷっちょ